it's being taken by force but not
without a fight
the town of rata line looks set to be
the first big gain of turkeys offensive
into Syria October we entered the town
of Roslin we are outskirts the fighter
who took this video is a member of a
Syrian rebel group they're working with
Ankara to push a us-backed Kurdish
militia out of town but these aren't the
actions of a disciplined army an ugly
show of contempt for their foe amid
warnings about ethnic cleansing from a
hilltop overlooking Russell iron from
the Turkish side we watched the
bombardment it's hard to believe a week
ago a group of US Special Forces was on
the ground here president Trump ordered
their pullout making way for the Turkish
invasion but hundreds more troops in
other areas partnered with the Kurds
remain in harm's way on Thursday night
came the news a u.s. position had come
under Turkish artillery fire to avoid
this kind of incident Turkey has been
telling the us-led coalition in Syria
where it's going to strike it's also
aware of the location of all US British
and other special forces still in this
region however a coalition source told
me that soldiers on the ground are
describing the Turks as non-compliant
Turkey denies targeting a US outpost but
it's hard to overstate the gravity of
American forces coming under fire from a
NATO ally Ankara appears set on
finishing its mission despite calls from
world leaders to stop we want to live in
peace and security with the people in
this region after having cleansed the
border from terrorists it's not just
Britain in the u.s. who think Turkey is
wrong russia's president - is unhappy
everyone who is illegitimately on the
territory of
any state in this case and Syrian Arab
Republic must leave this territory this
applies to all states and then there is
the Islamic state women linked to is
attack guards at the Syrian camp in this
complex war zone
it's the Kurds who've been left in
charge of is suspects but turkeys
assault has prompted some to leave their
post and join the fight an unintended
consequence could be a revival of the
terrorist groups fortunes Deborah Haynes
Sky News jalan pina on the turkey-syria
border